hey everyone welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for underground and
today
is gonna be the whole video is gonna be
about the event which is the monsters of
the other world
the fourth halloween event that we've
received and the fourth year this game
has been out so
we're keeping on a good track of four
for four a lot of new stuff
a whole lot of content a bunch of old
content coming back as well
with a loot vest to help us out with all
this stuff so as always like if you do
enjoy the subscribe if you do
let's get started with today's video so
first off for stuff that isn't related
to the event
paint patterns can now be set to empty
if you don't want to paint pattern any
of that garbage
set it to empty which is fantastic news
revenge meter will now be shown on the
player's emblem which is pretty sick
it might be a little bit harder to look
at when you're fighting but it's still
there and it's some good information and
feedback to give to you and your
teammates of
how much revenge you're giving the
person and how much he has left in his
gauge and stuff like that
on top of this they made ranked gear a
hell of a lot easier to obtain and the
xp boost costs as you're seeing on
screen
are massively lowered and they overall
are cheaper across the board depending
on how much you purchase throughout the
day
and now we get to the monsters of the
otherworld information this is going to
be a three week long event
and there's going to be a lot of stuff
involved in all these three weeks
first up there's going to be the usual
community orders that come with the
event and as well if you log in anytime
during
these three weeks even even if you don't
play a game as long as you log in
you will get an emblem outline which are
some nice little pumpkins
there's also a loot vest for the entire
duration of the event which makes it
easier to access the new content from
scavenging
and there's a lot of content for the
cosmetics and the weapons side of course
the main menu the verses and the faction
map have been changed within the event
which you can see on screen
there's like a green little portal on
the faction map and then there's like
this purple moon in the background with
a couple of these
random little spooky guys flying in the
background which is pretty cool
so definitely going to enjoy the main
menu this event has three map updates
which are going to be overwatch river 4
and the shard
those are going to be the new event maps
that we'll be playing of course these
are
already original maps in the game but
just with some slight updates of some
misty green color schemes
that are going to be throughout the map
there's also new minions for each of the
factions and they are now skeletons but
on top of that there's also frankenstein
monster
a tree monster and a pumpkin skeleton
which
i'm not exactly sure what's going on
with this cause the pumpkin skeleton
hovers which is really cool that's kind
of a first for the game as a hovering
minion
but the skeletons will be found in
normal game modes and even in the
special game modes as well like dominion
and tribute and the new
two new game modes we'll talk about
later in the video but the custom ones
were not mentioned they mentioned that
they might bring them up in the stream
and they never did
so maybe it's a future week that we'll
just have to find out and
figure out or maybe it's already in the
game and we just have to find it for
ourselves
they gave us no info on where these
custom ones are going to be placed
there was also of course more
customization like the effect which is
trick or treat or the monstrous live one
which are both effects
the tree bringer battle outfit and the
pumpkin ornament
there's also going to be four signatures
two of them are resurrection type
signatures
one of them is also a lycanthropy
possession and the pumpkin head
signature available for all heroes so
you can get these for anybody you want
of course these will have to be
purchased separately so this might cost
you a bit of steel if you want all of
them
the executions are the same from last
year except before
these were faction specific now any hero
can wield any of these
at any time we are no longer blocked due
to factions so
there's no need for that anymore you
just buy it for anybody you want there's
also an outfit and emote sale for the
halloween stuff
and a bunch of bundles which i'm gonna
try to explain in the best way possible
so there's three weeks to the event in
the first week there's going to be the
2017 bundle which has the option to
purchase year one content from
the 2017 halloween event week two is
going to have the 2018 bundle which is
the year two content from the halloween
event
and the week three event bundle is going
to be the 2019 one which is the year
three
halloween event all of them had separate
different types of content so
it's all gonna be new and exciting to
get but these are the past events so
maybe as a new player you didn't get to
experience it
those are going to be separate
throughout the weeks 2017 bundle will
only be available in the first week 2018
and the second and 2019 in the third
the 2020 bundle which is the newest
content for this year's
halloween event will be available
through all three of these so there's no
time restriction for that just
the start of the event the end of the
event but in every single week there
will also be a third bundle
which is just a combination of the three
so for example in week one you can have
the 2017 bundle which has all the old
content for the first year the halloween
event and all the stuff in its former
glory
and but then there's also the 2020
bundle which comes with all of the new
content that we're getting in this year
for halloween event but then there's the
combo bundle which is both the 2017
and both the 2020 content in the same
bundle
it's gonna be costing a hell of a lot
more but it might actually be cheaper
than buying these separately but of
course that's up to you
and that doesn't just go for the first
week that goes for the second week so
the second week is going to have the
2018 and the 2020
bundles together as well and then you
get the gist for the third week
so it's probably a bit confusing if i
say it out loud but you could probably
tell just by going in the store every
week as there should be three separate
options for the bundles
for all the characters a lot of content
but just make sure you have some steal
and this wouldn't be an event without
weapons and of course
these are orange pumpkin themed weapons
for the event tons of fantastic options
here for all the factions the color
scheme is nice orange black and silver
which
definitely fits the theme and depending
on the color scheme of your character
would fit fantastically
for the road map of the game modes
endless march is going to be in the
first two weeks with spooky slashers
coming up on the rear and the very last
week
both game modes can be played on the
three previous maps we just mentioned so
there's not one specific map per mode
which keeps things fresh
endless march is a return in game mode
classic 4v4 dominion except capturing an
objective will give you points of course
but
obviously can be taken away if the
capture point is lost
to get those true hard points you have
to kill the minion skeletons except the
minion skeletons are pretty tough
they're still one shot kills if you deal
damage to them but instead of doing that
my new damage they do to you
it's kind of like getting attacked by a
breach minion if not stronger
spooky slashers is the same as endless
march except the minions are
even tougher than in the other game mode
only being killed using a buff you get
from capturing objectives
so the plan for that game mode is
capture the objectives
get the buff and since it's a limited
time buff go
immediately right to the middle of the
map clear the minions for some hard
points
and then capture any objectives you
don't have or keep them
of course when grabbing that buff it
should be like a normal dominion where
the minions do minute damage to you and
you still one shot them so make sure to
keep that buff on hand
and of course the specific dates for
these game modes are going to be on
screen if you want to see that but tldr
of course
the endless march is going to be in the
first two weeks and spooky slashers will
be the third week game mode
and then a last thing to wrap all this
up quick reminder of course most of the
content that you saw in today's video
is free and scavengable through games
except the illustrious outfits
the emote and the execution assuming
they keep the trend with all this stuff
the illustrious outfits emotes and
executions have always been a thing that
have to be paid
so if any of those exist for this 2020
bundle which we've of course already
gone over so you could figure that out
you'll have to purchase those anything
else like the weapons the battle off at
the effect
you can get from just playing games of
course you can make it a little easier
by doing
with scavenger gear and getting the
weapons for steel but if you don't want
to go that route
you could just play the game and
hopefully you get lucky but like i said
the illustrious outfits the execution
that stuff
needs to be purchased with steel only
and cannot be gotten anywhere else
hopefully that was a quick and
understandable guide to the monsters of
the otherworld
event recap of course this event starts
on
october 22nd which is the day that this
video is live
and i believe it goes till november 12th
and if that date is accurate that means
it's also two days after the series x
and series s releases so
assuming you're an xbox player and you
got the new xbox on the release date
you can actually enjoy the last two days
of the event with that new 4k
graphics and it all looking beautiful on
the series x or series s
but the way that these console launches
have been going
probably not gonna get it on release but
if you did get it congrats to you as
that was pretty painful to even attempt
to get regardless i hope you liked the
video like
if you did subscribe if you're new with
that guys take care i'll see you in the
future video
and peace out
[Music]
[Music]
you